I love I love the first person that
claps who are you high-five round of
applause for this man up here started
the clap for the presenter I like it
hey everybody welcome to day three of
Google i/o yeah we feel it everyone
properly caffeinated today No
okay good good to know where we're
starting off as a team here all together
so I got to tell you they can't when we
actually got this talk agreed upon they
came to me and they said alright you
know we love the title of your talk GCP
on a shoestring budget we love the
narrative that you're trying to bring
helping developers save on money when do
you want to give the talk and I had one
answer I said day three 8:30 in the
morning no other possible opportunity
there and you want to know why because
the people who are willing to go through
two days of standing in the Sun and wake
up at 6:00 a.m. to stand in the security
line to get in the seats by 8:30 they
care about saving money on Google cloud
platform right yeah exactly so thank you
for being here
now when we get a chance to talk to a
lot of developers around the world I
find that there's generally two buckets
of people or two buckets of companies
that companies fall into when you're
talking about saving costs the first one
is your large companies with established
code bases they may have expected
workloads that come through Google cloud
but the predominant conversations we
have are hey you know if you make this
change in this change you can save a lot
of money and their response is always
along the lines of well how much would
that cost to implement we've got this
legatee legacy code base you know bill
over here really is attached to that API
we really don't want to get rid of that
basically any conversations we have with
these individuals they always have an
opportunity cost trade-off that they
have to make in their head before
they're willing to actually make the
changes to save the money right on the
other side though are the hustlers the
rise in grind right the startups the
people live in customer customer every
single day trying to get those costs as
low as possible because they know that
that's the key to keeping their business
afloat right now those are the people
hopefully that way
so early after two days of sunscreen and
dehydration to come to this sort of talk
and that's whom we're talking about
today all right now Google cloud
platform is huge we have a ton of
different products and quite frankly the
40 minutes that they've given me here we
don't have enough time to go through all
of them so today we're gonna focus on
three main things number one we're gonna
lay some foundation on the network and
show you how to save a little bit of
cost there just to kind of ease everyone
into what we're talking about then we're
going to talk about some ways to save
costs on compute and then we're gonna go
through a couple scenarios that
hopefully some of you fall into and
you'll have a little bit better time
attaching to your business model but the
most important thing you need to know is
that nothing I'm talking about today is
secret like none of this requires a
handshake or the right Google badge to
get this information about how to
optimize this stuff every piece of data
you're seeing today is available for you
to go get right now either using the
Google cloud platform pricing calculator
or looking at the pricing pages for the
individual products like this is it like
again it's not an Illuminati style thing
here like you can go run the same
analysis on everything you're doing on
your own so let's get started um
serving data this is this is where we're
gonna start today let's figure out what
is it cost to serve one terabyte of data
from Google Cloud Storage to your users
right just bare bare minimum discussion
here right let's just talk about serving
data now when you think about this you
have two components involved first off
is storage where you're storing your
data and second off is your network
costs we're actually transferring the
data now the cost for these are
dependent upon usage so for example
Google Cloud Storage what you pay is a
function of where you're hosting your
data alongside of how much you're
hosting it so for example if you're
actually hosting your data in US central
one region you're paying about two cents
per gig to actually store your data
however if you move to US East that
changes and if using a multi region
bucket then that changes as well on the
networking side it's a tiered cost
structure so if you're under one
terabyte you pay a different price than
if you're in the next tier of one
terabyte to 10 terabytes and 10
terabytes up and then this also changes
per region as well so for example if
you're transferring data from the Iowa
location which is US central one and
you're in the first tier of under one
terabyte you're paying about 12 cents a
gig
now with this in mind though we have to
point out something and again this is
not secret this is widely known is that
there's a whole tier of usage on Google
cloud that's absolutely free that you
get every single month that you can just
use this stuff no one cares about it
you're not going to get charged for it
right and this is it ranges from all
mostly all of our products but most
specifically for our case right now
we're worried about what is the free
tier for network and storage on the
storage side we actually get five
gigabytes of storage for free each month
each region so if you've got five gigs
in US East and five gigs in US west each
one of those is free right on the
network side we get about one gigabyte
of egress which is outbound data traffic
from a Merritt North American locations
to other other destinations and by the
way there's you will see many caveats of
little stars during this and you'll also
see a lot of little labels that says the
price of today right this is the cloud
prices change and if you discover this
video in the future you will undoubtedly
find that there's a discrepancy in the
prices so please make sure you check out
the documentation for the latest
so this is our frites here let's talk
about egress cost them so one terabyte
of data that we want to send so what
would this cost us so to store it we get
about one terabyte of data storing in US
central run
that's 1024 gigs - our five gig free
tier at two cents per gig about 20 bucks
a month just to store the data at rest
not too bad on the network side though
things get a little bit trickier so
we've got our one terabyte of data - the
gig in the free tier at 12 cents per gig
about 122 dollars a month for a total
about one hundred and forty three
dollars so storing the data transferring
a terabyte of data about 143 dollars
which isn't too bad I don't think but
the truth is that most of you actually
don't send your users directly to your
cloud storage bucket
chances are you have some proxy some
front-end that they're hitting first if
you're a website or something else that
this data is being routed through so
let's take a look at what that costs
basically the same so as long as you're
transferring information in the same
region between a cloud storage bucket
and a proxy or compute engine instance
it's free you don't have to worry about
that as long as it's in the same region
and then your egress rates are still the
same if they're coming from compute
engine or from cloud storage so
basically if you're transferring all
your data through a proxy you're paying
the same exact price as you would if it
was going from
storage directly the only difference is
that you're now actually paying for the
compute engine instance running there or
the compute function the cloud functions
instance or the App Engine instance so
basically as long as you're using a
proxy the basic serving costs don't
change but let's look at this from a
different way when we serve data to
people especially through cloud storage
one of the things we care about is
locality and latency so you want to get
our data as close to our users as
possible but we also want to do it as
cheaply as possible right so let's take
a look at that scenario so let's say
we're serving our data here we've got it
in US West 1 and we want to serve it to
a user in u.s. East 1 so we're going
across the continental US right price
here is still the same 143 dollars
doesn't matter where the users coming
from we still have the same cost at rest
and the same egress costs but we want to
get that data closer to the user so what
if we actually cloned that data in u.s.
East 1 and got it closer to the user
well of course at this point our egress
is still 12 cents no change there and
cloud storage itself we're now
duplicating the data between two buckets
so of course we're paying that extra two
cents a gig to copy it into this other
location so we're doubling our cost for
storage and we also have this extra 1
cent per gig transfer cost between them
because we're moving our data between
regions so now we actually have a cost
that's incurred with that so to actually
clone this data between regions we're
actually looking at 173 dollars not
ideal but it gets our data a little bit
closer but truth is we might be thinking
about this the wrong way so we do have
these things in Google Cloud Storage we
have regional buckets and multi-regional
buckets and what multi-regional buckets
do is effectively duplicate your data
between regions in an area so that you
don't have to do this cloning by
yourself the trick though is that
multi-regional buckets cost a little bit
more so let's take a look at that so if
we want to go from cloud storage right
to our users our egress rate from a
cloud storage multi-regional bucket by
the way there's going to be lots of
weird acronyms and terminology in this
talk it's labeled intermediate so
hopefully we're all moving together
twelve cents per gig egress however were
paying 2.6 cents per gig to store in a
multi-regional bucket which puts us at
about 26 dollars a month for that
storage instead of what we were paying
for the single region we're at about 149
there so not too much cost change but
the difference here is that when a user
in u.s. East one actually asks for this
asset Google handles the duplication of
getting that data closer to the
on your behalf and you don't have to
clone it yourself so we basically just
saved an extra thirty dollars by using a
multi regional bucket per month instead
of actually cloning it ourselves okay
sounds good so we've actually reduced
our cost inside the regional US but what
if we want to go international so we
want to serve this data to someone in
Europe right well let's take a look at
cloning there as well so again we have
our clone data in a u.s. multi region
and an EU multi region so obviously
we're duplicating our costs we have the
same amount of cost egress for us the EU
multi region which is selected for these
numbers however now because we're
transferring data between multi regions
in different areas we're actually at 12
cents per gig transfer so we actually
get a little bit pricier there 286
there's a result of this so if you're
trying to get your data to users in a
different area using the multi region
it's actually really expensive but let's
rethink this here so the goal again
we're shoestring right we want to make
this as cheap as possible we want to get
a data from the cheapest bucket we can
store in to the farthest away user as
fast as possible as cheap as possible we
already have this it's called the CDN
right we've all been working with these
so let's figure out what the cost is of
that so we've got our standard regional
Cloud Storage in u.s. wet in EU West at
about two cents a gig now for C DNS
there's two costs you need to be aware
of we have a fill cost and an egress
cost to fill data into the cache you're
looking at about 4 cents per gig to get
it into the CDN and that's worldwide
doesn't matter where you're going so if
you have data here and someone in
Nairobi asks for your asset it's 4 cents
per gig to cache it it's through to the
closest point of presence that Google
has there now egress from the CDN is
only 8 cents per gig so when you combine
these two together 4 cents and 8 cents
you actually end up at about 12 cents
per gig which is your standard outbound
egress rate however this is assuming a
one to one ratio so if you're actually
pushing a terabyte of fill and serving
that same terabyte you're gonna end up
at about a hundred and forty three
dollars to get that asset as close to
every user in the world without you
lifting a finger except making sure your
cache headers are turned on properly but
in reality this isn't how things work
out right typically the amount of cache
fill versus cache serve are quite
different so if you're actually in an
80/20 split here where 20% of your data
is filled into the cache and 80% is
actually served out you actually only
end up closer to about $91 so as long as
that ratio is on the serving side
instead of the filling side you're gonna
have a lot cheaper representation and
set up you're gonna get closer to that
shoestring value you want
so in general here if we're looking to
serve a terabyte of data the cheapest
thing we can do to get it to users
across the world as fast as possible is
simply to set your caching headers any
other tricks or any other smartness that
you're trying to do is gonna blow that
up right it's gonna make things more
expensive so find the cheapest bucket
that's as close to you as you can
tolerate put your data in that and then
turn on the CDN and like Google's point
of presence the network handle the rest
of it all right let's talk about compute
so Google cloud platform has a lot of
compute offerings but today we're only
going to talk about three of them first
off is Google compute engine which is
our standard VMs that run in the cloud
second is of course is Google cloud
functions which are our invocation based
compute resources and third of course is
Google App Engine which is both managed
and invocation based and for the sake of
this talk I'm gonna ignore things like
Google Google Group and Eddie's engine
and GAE flex because these actually tend
to price themselves closer to what GCE
is but for the sake of this 40-minute
talk we don't have to go into all the
nuances it's a little bit weird so I'm
just gonna ignore those we're gonna
focus on these three offerings right now
so by cost of course GCE is variable on
config depending on what configuration
you're using is how much you're going to
pay right the beefier the machine that
you're using in the configuration the
more you're gonna have to pay their
cloud functions though is a little bit
different cloud functions is about 40
cents per million calls that you make to
it and then there's also an additional
cost you have to be concerned with is
what we call gigabytes second and
gigahertz second and if you check out
the documentation there's a little bit
break to a little bit better break down
here I'm not going to get a chance to go
through it today and of course App
Engine is going to be point five five
cents to 30 cents per instance hour
depending on your config so this is the
default cost that you have here now on
the other side we have our free tiers
though right now here's where here's
where things get really cool in compute
engine if you're using an f1 micro
configuration it's free the whole month
no cost to you free inch three incidents
sitting in the cloud doing your bidding
as much as you'd like it all free on GCF
you got about two million invocations a
month or four hundred thousand gigabytes
seconds in two hundred thousand
gigahertz seconds right and on App
engines you have twenty eight instance
hours a day for an F one instance at
about nine hour nine instance hours a
day for a B one instance right and I
know there's not I know there's more
than twenty there's less than twenty
eight hours in a day so that gives you a
little bit of wiggle room in case your
extra instance spins up in an f1 so but
basically here when you look at GCE F
one micro and ji-ae f1 you kind of get
free compute as long as you're under a
certain strata of usage right with this
in mind let's take a look at an always
on costs so let's say you want to run a
box 24/7 for an entire month what does
that cost you so you know months have
different days and we always have leap
year and stuff like that so I'm just
gonna assume 730 hours that consists at
run time what we end up with if we're
using an f1 micro it's free the whole
month don't have to pay a thing however
when you bump up to an n1 standard one
because you want a little bit more
performance you start paying twenty four
dollars a month and 194 dollars a month
for an eight-core machine right this is
all on the cloud pricing page you can
see all of this and by the way this is
after a 30% sustained usage discount
which I'll get to in a second cloud
functions though we can't really compare
apples to apples because it's an
invocation based system we can't just
say consistently running so what I've
done here is I'm making the assumption
that you're getting one invocation to
your cloud functions service every
second for the entire month so you got
about 2.6 million invocations a month
that's going on there that'll lets us
kind of simulate what an always-on cost
would be for this it's about three
dollars and 51 cents to basically have a
GCF function running every second for an
entire month on App Engine you end up of
course in the f1 config it's free don't
have to change anything there however if
that second f1 instance actually spins
up you get a little spike in your
workload or you know all of a sudden you
you're the top of hacker news for some
reason you're gonna pay $36 for that
second instance to come on board of
course when you move up to an f2 or an
f4 which again or beefier machines you
get the $73 in the 146 dollar so
basically across the board here you can
see that in GCE and ji-ae
you get a stronger machine of course the
costs go up while GCF is still pretty
instance-based now here's the
interesting thing so there's our basic
cost
so obviously compute engine is the most
versatile thing we have right it can run
whatever code you want whatever instance
you want your images and all this other
stuff but the problem is it's also the
most expensive for what you're using so
it'd be really cool if we could figure
out how to make that as cost-effective
as our other services without having
some of the same limitations right so
for example if we just wanted to run our
code on GCF we have a problem is that
each function invocation has a nine
minute timeout right so you can't
actually get anything for more than nine
minutes on the other side on App Engine
you have a sixty second timeout on
requests but if you push that off to a
task later you get in to put the same
nine minute timeout so our goal here is
to figure out how to make GCE as cheap
as our other alternatives and the good
news is we can do this
first off let's take a look at the GCE
discounts now these are the things that
you really don't have to lift any
fingers to do to actually turn this
stuff on so first off is sustained views
so what we'll do on Google cloud
platform is analyze your usage and if
you have a sustained usage so you're
always on for a certain amount of time
we'll give you a default discount for
just running your instance with
consistency across the entire month
right if you're willing to make a phone
call to our sales team and can actually
commit to usage specific usage and say
I'm gonna run you know at least you know
in 2000 hours this month or 730 hours
this month you know it doesn't matter
what configuration you're using and you
don't have any pre definition of
specific upfront fees or whatever you
can actually get up to a 56% discount by
just making a phone call to talk to
sales so if you're a start-up and you're
starting to see a little bit more usage
and you need that dedicated resource and
you know you're gonna at least have one
or two instances running at a dedicated
fashion making that phone call and
getting that 50% savings is actually
pretty huge and of course right sizing
so what will happen is Google cloud
platform will actually analyze the usage
of your GC instances and look at how
you're using them and actually tell you
whether or not you're over provisioned
are under provisioned and you'll see a
little icon appear on the home page
that'll say hey if you click here we'll
reconfigure this for you and save you
money every month
likewise it'll say hey you're using this
pretty hard if you click here
beefed up your machine so that your
users get lower latency right so it's a
fun little button that you can just
click the deployment happens behind the
scenes you don't have to do anything so
this is this is kind of automatic stuff
however something that's a little bit
more drastic in terms of saving but does
require a little bit of work on your
part is something called pre-emptive now
what pre-emptive VMS are means that the
scheduler is allowed to kill your
instance when we need the resources in
Google cloud now that may sound really
scary but here's the fun part it'll
actually alert your instance before it
about to before it's about to get killed
so it'll send you a message and your
instance will say hey I'm about to
terminate you you've got roughly about
30 seconds to back up any data to some
persistent resource and then once it
kills your instance it'll start your
instance back up later and then you can
then go fetch that data and continue
working on right so if you allow us to
kill your instance when we need the time
we actually give you a substantial
discount if you're running an n1
standard that's pre-emptive instead of
paying the twenty four dollars a month
you get a 3x discount down to about
seven dollars a month for the same
instance and all you do is to have to
write the code so that you can lay over
those sorts of terminations after time
and the cool thing is that you can
actually put a load balancer in front of
that so if you need scalable compute and
you need the ability to allow these
things to die right but because you've
got so much load coming in you know one
of them going down means another one
might have to spin up putting a load
balancer in front of your preemptive
instances since load balancing is free
again means you're only paying about $7
a month per instance that you're
actually running of course if we can get
this a little bit cheaper in fact if we
actually use a micro instance there
instead we can actually get it down to
two dollars and 96 cents per month using
an f1 micro but because of the fact that
we have our load balancer and because of
the fact that we've re-engineered our
code to make sure that it can be fault
tolerant when it's killed we actually
have a massively scalable compute
resource that can handle itself getting
kicked over so if you've got large
amounts of workloads or individual
things you're processing lots of
individual files where you know
something can pick up processing 50%
wear something else left off this is an
extremely cheap solution for you
probably as cheap as I was actually able
to find in my research so in general if
you want to reduce your compute cost
you've got a couple things you need to
do first off is distribute workloads
that are based on
in vacations to either App Engine or
cloud functions those are going to be
the cheapest situations where you can
put your code and have them run if you
need something long running then leave
it back on compute engine but otherwise
try to push as much as you can to those
resources that's gonna be the cheapest
you can get likewise make sure that
you're making that phone call the sales
let them know that you're willing to
commit to a Content sustained use and
get that discount because that's gonna
be huge for their work jobs that you
actually need running consistently on
compute engine and likewise if you have
scalable needs a load balancer plus a
micro pre-emptive instance is pretty
much the highest flexibility lowest cost
scenario you can be in you know having a
bunch of little spiders doing your work
for you at scale is just as effective as
having one behemoth and doing it for a
higher price right all right so uh those
are our basics here so we've kind of
laid the groundwork for how we're gonna
evaluate these things and look at the
big picture between network and compute
now let's talk about some scenarios
personal privacy matters online right we
all kind of care about that especially
when we're logging into public Wi-Fi and
whatnot but sometimes I don't like
paying a subscription to some other
service to you know to handle a VPN
service so how cheap can we build our
own personal VPN service on Google cloud
now to be clear here I know that
personal security online is a very
hectic area right now and there's lots
of back-and-forth so to be very clear
I'm not going to talk today about why
you need a VPN I'm not gonna debate the
different software and libraries you can
use or having your own VPN but versus
being part of a cluster I'm basically
not going to talk about anything that PR
or legal would raise an eyebrow about
okay but I am gonna talk about how you
could run your own VPN on Google cloud
for as cheap as possible all right so
with this we have two components compute
and network pretty easy how a VPN
generally works is you have your client
that connects to some compute engine
instance that's running your VPN there's
a socket connection between the two
they're exchanging encrypted data and
then the compute engine instance or the
proxy will actually go out into the
fantastic internet and do all your
fetching for you return that data back
to your computer this is a high level
approximation if there's any security
engineers in the room I I apologize for
generalizing that to a point that I can
fit on a slide
so let's look at the free tier here how
cheap could we make this well if we use
our instance as an f1 micro then we know
we can get that for free and as long as
our usage is about less than one gig we
know that we can basically get that for
free as well right so if we're using an
f1 micro and our usage is less than one
gig we can get a VPN that we can use
whenever we want for free every single
month using Google cloud platform and if
you go in you only start to pay when you
go over that free gig so if you're just
using this to log on to Wi-Fi hotspots
when you're traveling around the world
you basically get this entire thing for
free no big deal but here's one of the
problems is is that if you're using a
pre-emptive version of that you have a
problem that you need to know where to
connect to and every time you reboot
that VM you have a new IP good news is
on Google cloud platform you can
actually reserve a static IP address and
as long as it's assigned and being used
it's free for you so you can go in
create your instance let it run get a
static reserved IP address that you can
use from your personal devices that
stick around waiting for you and you
don't pay anything right so again we can
run a personal VPN with a static IP for
nothing each got each month and again if
you eclipse the one gig free tier that's
when you actually start paying let's
talk about two specific scenarios here
what if you want better bandwidth so
what if you're traveling and you
actually want this VPN because you need
to stream some video from some different
location right well the important thing
you need to understand is that the
throughput for a GCE
instance changes based upon the core
count it's actually capped at the core
count so the more cores you have you can
see here that uh that on the on the side
there were at our 64 and 32 cores the
more cores you have the higher your TCP
throughput and this is where a lot of
people get caught up when they're trying
to increase their bandwidth for their
VPNs right because you'll notice that
then if moving up from the f1 micro the
next available option is the f1 small
which you would want to use because
that's going to be one of the cheapest
however you notice because the number of
core count is the same we actually don't
get any better bandwidth by moving to
there even though it's only $14 a month
moving on to the next one the actual
first stage you get where you actually
get some bandwidth increase is actually
the n1 standard so unfortunately if
you're moving up and trying to get
better bandwidth you
get it there you have to start paying
$24 a month for your VPN incidents
unless of course it's pre-emptive in
which case you get it down to seven
dollars a month but then you have to
deal with what happens when you're in
the middle of a session in your your VPN
decides to die so let's talk about
something I deal with a lot traveling
right so a lot of us are international
nomads we spend a lot of time traveling
around going to conferences talking to
customers and whatnot it'd be really
nice if we had our VPN follow us because
if we boot up a VPN and us central one
and yet we're in Malaysia you know we
don't want to wait for our packet to go
all the way to the US and then come back
to us because that's just gonna make our
experience bad so I actually put
together a little pack for this that I
wanted to share with everybody so it
turns out that you can actually run a
Google compute engine API is from Google
cloud functions so I actually wrote a
little web location that I host that
when I load it while I'm traveling it'll
figure out what my location is and in
Google cloud functions it'll figure out
what the closest zone is that I can run
an f-1 instance it'll kill whatever the
previous VPN instance I have is and
actually create a brand new instance as
close to me as possible so as I'm
traveling I can basically just click a
single button kill the old VM and create
the new VM as close to me as possible no
matter where I am in the world again for
free because then I'm not doing more
than 2 million invocations and cloud
functions per month so this is really
nice so if you want to get the people in
your family using your VPN and maybe
charge them $10 a month this might be a
nice little racket to play Thanksgiving
all right so let's talk about something
a little bit closer to home for a lot of
you is a wordpress site right anyone
WordPress experts in here a couple
people still no caffeine in the house I
like that I like that we're closer to 9
a.m. now and everyone's still sleeping
this is good so WordPress is a large and
unwieldy beast right there's lots of
different components involved in lots of
different ways you can take this so when
you actually google for WordPress Google
cloud platform the first thing you're
actually introduced to is a page for our
Google cloud launcher with all of these
pre-configured operations that allow you
to one-click deploy a wordpress instance
to your google cloud account and just
get up and start moving right so you can
click any of these and they have a bunch
of different configurations of how you
want it all set up
however the default setup for this is
actually less than ideal from an expense
perspective right so these are all going
to be set up with an n1 standard one
which is $24 a month and of course
you're still paying that 12 cents
outbound egress from there right so this
is putting us in something we've seen
before but let's talk about complexity
here so what if you're using the
simplest WordPress site possible well
obviously you don't nee and you're only
using a single instance right because
you don't have that number you know that
many number of users well you can
actually use the f1 micro for this
instead which is free per month and
again if you're under one gigabyte of a
bound egress you can actually get that
for free as well so if you're a
brand-new startup right and your friends
are all like hey go sign up for this
website over here you know it's $10 a
month the hole for your WordPress site
and you're still living on ramen right
out of the VC incubator along with 40
other people this actually saves you
that $10 a month to buy more ramen yeah
but the question that we have then is
this but is the concept that we're free
as long as we're under the free tier and
this is something I've been harping on
for a while is what is the cost before
we eclipse that right so if we assume
that we've got Network of one gigabyte
free and our default WordPress site that
you deploy on App Engine is about two
hundred and seventy 2k per visitor it
means you can get roughly about 3,800
visitors a month before you eclipse that
bandwidth and actually have to start
paying this is a really important number
for startups for the hustle and flow
type people right knowing how many
visitors you can actually take before
you have to start paying money and where
you want to start optimizing all of that
data and of course we could go into a
massive diatribe about how to properly
optimize your images and compress your
headers and serve all that data that's a
different talk right now we're just
talking about the fundamentals okay so
right here we basically say if we're
under roughly about 4,000 users a month
we should be okay and always in the free
tier right and of course if you turn on
caching headers that'll put things going
into the CDN so to increase this number
significantly because the more users you
have they hit the same content doesn't
come out of your main bucket it comes
out of a different bucket and you get
this you get a lot more users to hit
your information but what if you
actually end up on the top of hacker
news suddenly and you need to start
scaling up and down well the cool thing
here is that putting the load balancer
between the CDN actually lets you do
this you end up with the same egress
eight cents per gig outbound in the same
Phil four cents per gig Phil and we can
actually end up with the f1 micro the
problem now we have though is because we
have a number of instances instead of a
single one you need a persistent s MySQL
instance for each of your compute
instances to be able to sync between now
unfortunately as of today I could not
find a way to get a free tier setup with
the SQL instance so that's gonna be
around twenty nine dollars a month so if
you're above that four thousand user
mark and you're expecting scaling the
minimum cost you're going to end up
paying is around twenty nine dollars
just to make sure that cloud SQL
instance is sitting around or you could
run it on your own n1 standard or f1
micro and deal with all of the
provisioning and everything else
yourself now there it's worth noting
here that there's also a plug-in for App
Engine so if you're running WordPress
and you want to run it on a pinch
instead of dealing with all that other
stuff you can actually run it on an f1
micro instance or f1 instance on
WordPress on App Engine and get that
down to about zero dollars a month
unfortunately you still need the SQL
scalable back-end which runs on its own
instance at about $29 a month as well so
something to think about in general if
you're doing WordPress on Google cloud
platform I got to tell you there's three
strata you need to think about to make
sure you're really thinking about your
shoestring style budget if you're under
4,000 visitors just use an f1 micro and
turn on the CDN and you'll basically get
the whole thing for free which is
fantastic right that's where we all want
to be if you're above 4,000 visitors
then you need to start thinking about
stringing together compute engine plus
the load balancer plus the CDN and plus
the SQL option or using App Engine to do
the same because you have enough users
there you need to start making sure that
you're you're doing things properly
however I got to tell you that there is
a number of hosted WordPress companies
that have their backends built on Google
cloud platform that do offer you a
subscription-based service so paying
four dollars a month they'll host your
WordPress site they'll deal with all the
scalability they'll deal with all the
security updates they'll make sure
everything is running in the background
you don't have to lift a finger and it
might be a cheaper option for you to
fall into that bucket if you're above
4,000 visitors so that might be
something to look at - all right final
topic for the day video content site on
the shoestring budget so with these
things
in mind we have to look at what it would
take to make like a an education website
or like an online MOOC right you have
students that log in they have some data
they want to look at they they watch
some videos they take some tests you
know maybe you have maybe a sports site
that's streaming all of your high school
sports games and you've got a lot of
video they need to transfer but you have
some combination of rich multimedia and
rich website presence right so with a
standard layout here you would probably
have to store that video data in Google
Cloud storage right and serve that right
to the user so that you can get
streaming capability right you don't
want that going through a proxy you want
that coming straight to the source there
on the website side you probably have an
Apache instance or maybe a wordpress
instance is actually hosting your
website it's got some connection to some
relational database right so we can keep
track of who the users are what data
they've seen and any other key words
that you need and then of course you've
got your standard load balancing and CDN
in front of that so you can scale up
scale down and make sure that your data
is consistently sent to users around the
world this gets pretty pricey
unfortunately right you're looking at
$24 for the compute engines per instance
a month you're looking at a $29 for the
cloud SQL instance of course you've got
your fill and your egress costs but
where you really get hit here of course
is serving that video now as of today
and again this can change in the future
internet if you're watching this
sometime in the future as of today the
cloud CDN that's coming from Google
Cloud Storage does not cache 206
responses from an HTTP header 206
responses are the ones that are used for
streaming video which means as your
streaming video it's not going through
the cache right so we have to be very
cautious of this which means we're going
basically into the 12 cents per gig
ratio if we're streaming data directly
from Google Cloud Storage not really
ideal this whole thing can get pretty
costly but there actually is a solution
if you're willing to make a couple
changes we can get this almost down to
free instead of all of this costs so
first off if you're willing to make some
changes leave your CDN in place but
instead of actually using a dedicated
compute engine instance switch over your
page serving to be something invocation
based like cloud functions minimize all
of your crazy complexity down to
something that he can use a template for
to just scrape the data together put it
together send it down on the HT
he requests as easy as possible make an
invocation base you don't really need to
do that much in the backend right and as
long as you're under two million page
views a month you can basically get that
entire serving process for free which is
pretty nice likewise instead of using
cloud SQL try to use cloud datastore for
your relational database right if you're
on a shoestring budget datastore will
still give you the performance you need
because most of it is fetch based if
you're using a website like this and it
has its own free tier right if you're
under one gigabyte of stored data and
you're doing less than five hundred
thousand reads and a hundred thousand
writes per month you basically pay
nothing which I think this is right in
the range of a MOOC style startup
because you don't really have all the
visitors you need yet and even the
successful ones are probably not doing
five hundred thousand one hundred
thousand per month and you know a
gigabyte of relational data is actually
a lot in that scenario so we can
basically get our entire website serving
and back-end storage for about zero
dollars now the problem though is what
do we do about the video content right
because there's no real other place to
store this in Google Cloud storage
because 206 responses my only solution
here a little bit of a hack store all
your video in youtube upload your video
to YouTube leave it is unlisted right
and basically when you're streaming your
embedded URLs down to your user
obfuscate the hell out of your code so
they can't figure out where the video
urls are if you can set it up this way
you get it the entire content serving
and video production platform for free a
lot of chuckles yes this slide is very
contentious internally we had a lot of
talks and a lot of talks internally
about whether or not that last little
animation should be in this talk at all
so with that I want to thank you for
your time today I want to thank you for
being the hustlers and the grinders
working on your costs to every single
day I want to thank you for waking up
this early to hear another bald man
ranted you most importantly if you care
about cost if you care about the
performance of your cloud applications I
got to encourage you to check out our
YouTube channel for Google cloud
platform we have a ton of amazing people
working on May
content to help you lower your costs
increase your scalability and basically
get your cloud application to where you
want it as cheap as possible with that
thank you say sunscreen to stay hydrated
enjoy your last day of Google i/o thank
you very much
[Music]